comment les sans-abris sont-ils encadrés
sera-t-on vraiment en sécurité voilà
quelques-unes des inquiétudes soulevées
hier soir en réunion publique par les
riverains de la rue Édouard vaillant à
Tours à la fin du mois les SDF
actuellement hébergé en tiny House en
caravane dans le quartier centralegonde
viendront s'installer près de la gare
routière romain Delville
une réunion publique avant
l'installation de Tiny House pour
héberger des personnes sans abri rue
Édouard vaillant rappelle dans ces
questions et ses remarques la réunion
publique qui a précédé l'installation
des tiny House dans le quartier centrale
de gondes il y a un an
ils respectent que personne ils font
peur à tout le monde devient le quartier
de la gare on peut pas dire que c'est un
quartier maintenant sécurisant
[Musique]
c'est si le portail doit être fermé
d'une façon électrique pour la nuit si
une fermeture
le site de la rue Édouard vaillant et
son portail le voici 2900 mètres carrés
le long des voies de chemin de fer sur
lesquels seront disposés cette tiny
House et si caravanes comme celle-ci
actuellement à sainte-rade les travaux
de dépollution les réseaux d'eau et
d'électricité le raccordement au
tout-à-l'égout sont effectués le
déménagement est programmé d'ici une
dizaine de jours un déménagement qui
suscite chez certaines et certains
intervenants des craintes à la gare
il y a des activités autour c'est ça
rassure par rapport à ça si on
me sentais de la sécurité je pourrais au
moins appeler que ici dans ce quartier
là je ne passerai plus à pied c'est pas
possible à 10h30 du soir parce que je ne
sais pas c'est peut-être un sentiment
mais le sentiment d'insécurité il faut
pas l'oublier si on sort le soir si on a
affaire à des gens qui se droguent ou
qui boivent s'ils ont le quartier libre
ben on a peur dans le quartier
maintenant ça va être ça va pas être
facile ces appréhensions la mairie de
tourne les néglige pas et c'est
représentants rappellent que le
dispositif à Sainte-Radegonde n'a pas
créé de troubles à l'ordre public dans
le quartier des rondes supplémentaires
de la police sont en outre-programmés
bien sûr on a une police municipale qui
est sensibilisée à ce sujet qui fera des
passages joignables bien sûr en cas de
difficultés et puis l'association aussi
a donné beaucoup de garanties quelqu'un
sera présent sur le site 24 heures sur
24 et donc en cas de problème il y aura
toujours un interlocuteur et je pense
que ça c'est des ingrédients importants
pour rassurer les riverains et les
riveraines après un an d'existence le
dispositif de Sainte-Radegonde des
ménages rue Édouard vaillant le bail et
le financement par l'État sont fixés
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2024